buen día pues básicamente el presidente
donald trump se mostró en esta cerca de
una hora que duró su discurso como el
único líder que puede restaurar el orden
en la nación después de muchas protestas
que hemos visto durante todo este año en
búsqueda de justicia racial que reclaman
cientos de ciudadanos pero también
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos civiles y fueron estas mismas
protestas las que se registraron en
frente de la casa blanca justo cuando el
mandatario daba su discurso en el ala
sur en los jardines exteriores la gente
los manifestantes gritaban pensé si
trump fuera ya y sin justicia no hay paz
estas son otras manifestaciones que
también se esperan se registran en el
día de hoy pero el mandatario también se
mostró en su discurso como el único que
puede llevar a un crecimiento económico
sostenido en los eeuu con su propuesta
de crear 10 millones de trabajos en 10
meses el tema también más esperado era
el manejo que iba a dar sobre en la
pandemia y el mandatario decidió
no hablar de cifras de por ejemplo los
20 millones de personas que se
encuentran sin empleo más de 170 mil
personas que han perdido la vida durante
la pandemia y se centró en prometer una
vacuna para final de año y para que todo
vuelva a la normalidad en 2021 con
reapertura de escuelas y de negocios
también junto a su mensaje del discurso
se podía ver como los cerca de 1500
asistentes que fueron a la casa blanca
rompieron las normas del distrito de
columbia ya que no se podían registrar
aglomeraciones de más de 50 personas y
finalmente el mandatario habló en
términos acerca de su contrincante
críticas hacia job airén asegurando que
sino eeuu enfrentaría socialismo
anarquía comunismo lo que contrasta con
las expresiones que vimos por parte de
la convención demócrata como por ejemplo
racismo en los eeuu al igual que temor y
miedo así que los dos
digamos partidos apelaron más al miedo
de los votantes y veremos finalmente en
noviembre 3 en las urnas cuál de estos
dos mensajes llegó a los votantes